le 61e festival de cannes
une minute de silence a été observée
aujourd'hui pour les victimes du séisme
en chine par le réalisateur et l'équipe
du seul film chinois en compétition pour
la palme d'or 24 city canal écoute du
monde d'abord à travers ses films à 72
ans woody allen vient de présenter sa
dernière comédie dominique poncet
laurent fabius
c'est la dixième fois qu'il vient
présenter un film à cannes rien à faire
de loin il aura toujours l'air d'un
enfant perdu pourtant dès que la caméra
s'approche de son visage impossible pour
lui de dissimuler plus longtemps sa
malice et sa fantaisie
surtout s'il est entouré par de très
jolies femmes en l'occurrence ici
penelope cruz et rebecca rôle
deux des comédiennes de son nouveau film
un film tourné dans le genre qu'il
affectionne le plus que la comédie
romantique et sentimentale vicky
cristina barcelona et sont ils mettent
en scène un chassé croisé amoureux dans
la barcelone aujourd'hui les dialogues
sont étincelants l'humour évidemment
décalé penélope cruz à dorer sous 10
c'est à l'âme tellement drôle tellement
généreux tellement talentueuse il
comprend tout au quart de tour et en
plus il respecte ses acteurs c'est
vraiment un type génial génial mais
têtue impossible de lui faire monter les
marches avec un autre objectif que celui
du plaisir
j'adore venir à cannes et à chaque fois
c'est une belle expérience mais essayer
de faire croire que mon film et meilleur
moins bon qu'un autre ça je ne veux pas
je ne crois pas d'un genre l'autre à
cannes
l'équipe de charlie hebdo est venu
présenter un documentaire réalisé autour
du procès intenté à l'hebdomadaire en
février 2007 à la suite de l'apparition
des caricatures de mahomet intitulé
c'est dur d'être aimé par des cons
ce documentaire a fait choc sur la
croisette où l'on sait que la mainmise
de toute forme d'intégrisme religieux
entraînerait la privation de la liberté
d'expression et donc entre autres la
mort du festival et borné par les
intégristes et là il dit que ce film
soit présenté à cannes même en
compétition a réjoui tout l'équipe donc
abus le monter les marches pour défendre
la laïcité c'est pas mal quand même
avis aux amateurs ce documentaire d'une
force exceptionnelle ne sera pas dans
les salles avant l'automne